hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Gregory Alma and my name is jaw we're
going to do the movie news of the week
from februari 26 through March third oh
boy in six minutes or less the latest
moving the x-men universe Logan
premiered number one at the box office
this past weekend and it's called a
ninety-three percent on rotten tomatoes
the film continues the streak of darker
comic book movies such as mattis feelin
Batman V Superman this one is good
that's only cuz we're marble fanboys
hahaha you guys might not know this but
something got [ __ ] up with the Oscars
this year lala land was announced to be
the best picture winner which it was but
the wrong card was given to the
presenters and the real best picture of
the year was moonlight is such [ __ ]
lala land deserve to win best picture
did you even see my life no I movie just
sounds like my life why would I want to
relive that Disney wants to reboot wrong
with jared leto the director joseph
kosinski said that the third tron film
would take place both in the real world
end the great now this is great news
because Jared Leto's Joker was widely
praised as being much better than Heath
Ledger's performance so why not throw
him in another reboot and not [ __ ] that
one up to James mingled is reportedly
working on a black and white version of
the Logan movie this is awesome I love
black and white I agree the acting
writing directing cinematography visual
effects set designs action scenes were
all fantastic to look at I hated that it
was in color that really brought the
film down for me I mean why would I want
to see colors in a calm equipment this
is actually television news but I think
it's interesting American Horror Story
showrunner bride Murphy says that season
7 will begin on election night in case
you haven't heard real-life [ __ ]
grabbing racist monster Donald Trump is
President of the United States of
America I think this is the exact show
America needs right now yes a show where
when every episode is done we can just
go to Twitter and continue living the
real
for our story when it's done the
director of kubo is a two strings Travis
Knight will be directing the new
transformers spin-off bumblebee I think
it's a smart because anytime the
talented small-time director leaps into
a major blockbuster franchise it always
works that's true Gavin hood with x-men
origins wolverine marc forster with
quantum of solace and just frank and tim
story for all the Fantastic Four movie
yes and the Transformers films are
universally praised as cinematic
masterpieces so you know the studios are
just let's Travis Knight make the the
art piece he wants to me the star of
stranger things David harbour may
potentially be cast as cable in the new
Deadpool movie I don't know anything
about cable but I guess this is exciting
news I don't know anything about cable
either but I also guess that this is
probably exciting it why do any research
when the movie news have to be presented
in six minutes or less it's reported
that the engineers from Prometheus will
still be part of the mythology and alien
covenant let's just hope that this time
we'll get some actual answers well the
big question is why did they create the
humans that the engineers wouldn't have
that answer because God and Jesus
created the humans okay great this is a
science fiction movie but its own rules
those are your biblical beliefs you know
I don't think the tube well I'm if it's
a movie I want to be believed you know
what could be real about this and it's
just a proven science fact that God and
Jesus built the world in seven days but
I mean it and what if that mythology
doesn't exist in this mythology you know
like they can it's a fancy they can have
their own well mythology is not real
this is I'm talking about real life this
is it a document sure the Bible written
by Gibson this is like it
let's Dipper the movie news of this week
tune in next week where will be more
movie news recap that you already hurt
you can subscribe to the real reject
follow John on Risa Jerry on Instagram
and Twitter and shout out to Collider
videos the collider Clark wolf Lord hot
and sexy good job on your last tree is
too and your sexy professional
professionalism for our national defense
in the workplace